you know for a lot of people watching  they may not have the financial  resources to make it an hour when I used  to do all the editing by the way all my  editing was record stop post I became an  improv no editing no lighting no audio  maker with Wine Library TV because I  didn't have the capabilities or the  money to hire someone to do it I did  that for seven years people forget that  part they don't see that Journey they  only see the end from day one it was in  my soul that all the lighting didn't  have to be perfect nothing had to be  perfect except the [ __ ] coming out of my  mouth production value matters it's  awesome and it can work and be a huge  Factor but it's an and not an or it can  be a factor but you can just be a factor  of making real [ __ ] going through real  life just doing it like this